alors contrairement à la présidence
moldave maya saône doubs qui parle de
tensions internes en transnistrie et se
garde bien de pointer du doigt la russie
selon de nombreuses déclarations
d'officiels et de commentateurs en
ukraine à kiev il n'y aucun doute que la
russie serait bien derrière ces
explosions en transnistrie le but selon
les ukrainiens seraient d'inculper soit
l'ukraine soit la moldavie et de se
servir de ces explosions comme un
prétexte pour une action militaire en
moldavie selon les renseignements
militaires ukrainiens les forces russes
qui sont stationnés en transnistrie ont
été mises en état d' alerte certains
commentateurs en ukraine aussi lycée
explosion en transnistrie au
bombardement d'un pont dans la région
d'odessa qui est juste au sud de la
frontière avec la transnistrie ils
disent que la russie préparait peut-être
une action militaire de grande envergure
qui concernerait non seulement la
moldavie mais aussi ce coin de l'extrême
sud ouest de l'ukraine au sud-ouest de
dessin